you mentioned
that you were hanging with a girl and
that maybe it got a
sexual I wouldn't say sexual just you
know like easy stuff
easy stuff I couldn't imagine what is
dating a girl would be easiest
especially when he [__] just hang out
make out stuff like that you know like
not anywhere in like a public you know
just hang out make out easy stuff I
think you should if you're gonna go get
you have to go in public you have to
give people the joy of watching it I
love easy stuff I love the sound of that
also wait you are someone that does not
scream easy said
[Music]
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
let therapy be your map with betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today
to get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help.com trash Tuesday stop
throwing your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday that's rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday rocketmoney.com
trash Tuesday hi slugs I am back on the
road doing stand up I'm having so much
fun talking with you guys and answering
your very weird questions and I love
sharing my material with you I am going
to be in New York City next I'm going to
be at Joe's Pub July 19th through 23rd
and I'm coming to the DC Improv
September 28th Boston I'll be at the
Wilbur Madison Wisconsin
um Detroit and Chicago all this fall get
tickets at astronice.com and I believe
I'm adding San Diego as well
I love you
hey guys I'm so excited to see my
sluggies I am on tour always with the
welcome to anniewood tour I'm going to
be in Philadelphia my hometown August
11th and 12th look I know it's summer
but I don't care summer ends on the 10th
of August now and you're gonna come to
these shows come hang out with me I
can't wait to see you
um I'll also be in Calgary at The Great
Outdoors Comedy Festival with Andrew
Schultz August 27th and I'll be in
Austin Texas October 6th and 7th
um I will be at the Regent Theater with
the Liam McSweeney live show on July
12th come see me there as well and I
have my podcast every Thursday uh Annie
would come check it out it's me and Todd
and we're end up guess talking about
tavarians baby
thank you Todd only watches lesbian porn
that's why I love that I totally get
that I think I most 95 of the time I'm
watching lesbian porn yeah it makes
sense to me it's like he's he wants to
look at [__] he doesn't want to look at
other dicks doesn't it make sense like
why he's into like a girl like me
because I'm so like like I'm definitely
like a pegger without actually pegging
you know what I mean Peg energy I Peg
Bundy energy
I like to I feel like Todd's going to
reveal that he wants to be packed but he
keeps saying he isn't going to but it's
like and how would you feel about that I
would one million percent
do it try it yeah I'm not a lesbian porn
girl like I I want to be degraded like I
need to you know you do look like a
little bit what the [__] remember when
he did oh you didn't watch [__] what
did you watch
oh that's right I didn't think they did
a cover of that do you like do you like
porn at all no
wait I try not to watch it either I I
just don't like every once in a while I
like it I used to really like James Dean
before you know all that but I liked
what I liked about him was that it was
like forcing porn stars to have real
orgasms but then I guess there was too
much forcing
allegedly do you watch porn I do I feel
like now it's like it's all it's so easy
to act as I bet like middle schoolers
and even less you know like that why'd
you have to go there with it
I just feel like that's where it goes
like that's where you start feeling yeah
you know oh it's easy did I tell you
guys this happened to one of my A friend
of mine has like teen kids and she found
uh her daughter had made like a porn
video like a pretty young daughter whoa
I mean that is well didn't you do that
yeah
i.ei you're right
you need to work on your fear of me I'm
scared of everyone hitting me I you know
what that makes me think we gotta hit
you yeah
Esther but when have you ever been hit I
don't know but I this used to always be
a thing like with my guy friends and
stuff they would literally just go like
this and they're like why are you why
did you think I was about to hit I have
a question did um during P during PE
then balls just happened to find your
head or your face yes and I you're damn
right were they spiking down I mean it
could be tall they always hit me in the
head and I always went to the nurse's
office and made a meal out of it it hit
me like you've never actually been
stopping such a teen sex thing
but you haven't actually been like
spanked or or like hit right what'd you
say [__] really wants to do it too I
think we should I need two things I need
this summer two things I need this
summer okay I need to teach you how to
swim and take a hit and then Annie and I
need to jump you
the fact that you've never been hit it's
like taking something yeah just take it
so you know how it's not you never have
to live in middle school that like
punched you in the side of the head yeah
people like flicking their nails off to
[__] me up I'll throw you in a bush what
about like a physical fight with like a
referee like I don't want to just have
to do not pass out that many boners
right now no like like I want to be able
to defend myself
[Applause]
to defend yourself but you are better
I've never heard you say something like
this in your life you want to be able to
defend yourself I remember that's the
that's the boldest thing I've heard
kalila fights me but I have Annie on my
team so it's just you guys fighting each
other
for Honor somehow we're fighting over
you you figured that out she's clip
clapping she sometimes have monetized it
just for herself pulls out the lube none
of us make a dollar she's made like
[__] 100 Grand an hour
all right I'm in
um I saw what you did over the weekend
um while I was lesbianing out you were
trying to set me up with a Pete Davidson
okay so did he break up with that girl I
don't know and I don't care you're mean
no I'm not you're mean you're mean 10
minutes of this you're mean
I performed at good nights in Raleigh
which they remodeled and our friend that
the man I love him he's so awesome
um yeah I love him so much
but so the next act after me who is
coming to town was Pete Davidson which
I'm like why is he playing this small
Comedy Club but he was doing 15 shows
and
um
the guy asked me to sign the wall there
and so I did and underneath my name
since I knew and it's a fresh wall
because they just remodeled and since I
knew who was coming next I left him a
little message and I said Pete I think
you should date kalila smiley face
and so he will see that he will be
sitting in that green room for the next
seven days I can't wait to get the call
sometimes I get calls from Pete asking
for my friend's phone numbers yeah but I
know those friends are
are
in you know top tier you're up there
baby I mean the [__] is but you know
what I mean the the image right now is
oh my God I can't he would be so lucky
today thank you yeah he's into we both
have like IBS I think or stomach
problems yeah he has Crohn's
okay I don't have Crohn's but I have
Colitis I think he has groans I think he
just looks like he has Chrome no no no
he has he has curls I think Ariana like
defended him one time and said like
Jewish people had Crohn's uh Johnny
Pemberton has Crone why do you know stop
this stop this Esther you've grown
you're so powerful skinny and young
honestly you look like you could have
Croods it's it's skinny young looking
people no it's not first of all it's not
funny it's a disease I have cousins who
have it you don't give a [__] about your
cousin you act like you care about your
cousin that's also true both things can
be true get over your you are supposed
to be aborted cousin
oh
but anyways I just I don't know I'm
cooking up a little I think a little doo
doo because you have Crohn's no he
[__] does no a little love narrative
a storyline she's sick a manifestation
because you know oh my God they gave her
one commercial to direct and look at her
she's like I can direct the world she's
like you're gonna need a morning after
pill after this
because you're a Julie it's all a secret
commercial for Julie wait this is oh
yeah I didn't care we're actually
commercial I submitted to the brand
they're like Esther we did not ask for
this but no because subliminal messaging
works just so you know all those
advertisements we see over the years
where it's like Doritos gushers whatever
when we were kids we'll never forget
those he is going to be sitting in that
room staring at that wall for eight days
it's gonna say that's what you do in the
Green Room
you don't work on your jokes or like
you don't wait you don't sit down by
yourself just read the cop I don't you
know read the wall
okay
[Laughter]
yeah so it's not a prison
you don't do push-ups you're there by
choice you know you're choose to go you
can leave it's a it's a gift we get to
do it it's a lovely job me
I mean I will thank you Esther I think
you've done a really good job
um I'm trying to say I would love that
that would actually be so cute with Pete
I like pizza yeah I think so I want that
big dick in my girl it's oh my God I
don't I want that big [__] no if you
really have a big [__] yeah because you
know I'm not a really big [__] kind of
guy but girl it's time
enough here's why see he is dating a lot
right like pee we love you we're you
know he's in love I think right now he's
currently in love maybe maybe who knows
but I'm just saying it's like he needs a
girl did you say friend of the show yeah
a friend of the show Pete Davidson so
sad hey he was on my old podcast weird
adults that makes him a friend when he
was underage
his dad was still alive 911 hadn't
happened it was 3 9 11.
I think that what he needs is a woman
who is beautiful you thinking you know
what a person needs is so disgusting and
calling them a friend of the show and
there's no way you have his phone number
there's no way of anything I have a
phone number associated with his name at
one point we have a couple old versions
of people yeah
are you guys going to change your phone
numbers by the way what kind of a
question is that that's the dumbest what
that's such a cool question are you
thinking I think that is a cool question
to ask you stupid idiot by the way does
Fame hungry loser to say that like
starve to be like this Fame you're going
up to Kylie Jenner you're disgusting I
think Kylie Jenner doesn't change her
phone number it was Kendall [__] I
don't know the difference I feel like
Kylie would have been nicer Kylie would
have been nicer thank you chose the
wrong Hollywood no one would be nice too
by the way I'm so sorry none of the
Kardashians would be nice to you I
disagree and I'm gonna prove you wrong
one day I hope you do I'm gonna have
grasshopper
were you guys a
Jay Leno or a David Letterman household
both
David Letterman for me I have to draw a
very very very important Line in the
Sand right now I'm tired of these rules
okay well I'm it's just not a thing and
I know what you're gonna do one last one
this is like when you Seinfeld our
friends yeah no I actually how about
this how about I'm the [__] that
doesn't I pick it all I get it all do
you want to be like me I can have it all
no I can have it all right business
manager can I have that purse on this
moment forward I will only associate
with people who were Letterman
households you fault you do because you
are both I will make an exception
because here's what I'll tell you
Letterman obviously was like our our
main because he's [__] so sharp of me
he was mean he's just the coolest he's
so mean it's so good he's [__] mean
and then but Jay I personally really
love Jay and then having I love Jay Leno
have you worked with him at Flappers or
anything he's around he is
amazing he's so good he'll talk to you
he'll like he'll tell you stuff I'm I'm
standing strong in My Line in the Sand
Leno as a person is a separate issue
then what late night show did you grow
up watching how about that we separated
I I watched them both I watched them
both I liked them both I'd like back and
forth I have 80d I choose them I choose
everything
there's not one thing I choose I choose
do you want me to make a choice right
now
bless you thank you I sneeze in threes
sorry did you guys have TV in the
Philippines we did Mommy you sure did
you were Letterman
well I think things got to us a little
slow so my dad was still stuck on like
reruns so like Carson
oh yeah Johnny Carson and Johnny Carson
who your dad liked I'm sure that would
be who you like
shut the hell up I only watched The
Twilight Zone I like black and white
aren't I so intriguing
I'm cool I'm Different oh God I'm a
quirky girl you're a pygmy girl but for
like grandpas
no lies detected that is correct you
know what I was realizing I have a pikmi
thing in my that's so okay so I when I
was going through and getting rid of all
of my like
um
things that I'm mailing list I'm
subscribed to I mean my my Gmail is wild
I mean it is just yeah Memorial Day
sales no digital clutter is like scary
it's like all I have like I think back
in the day when I wasn't working a lot I
was like
I want to feel like things are happening
so I was like click subscribe all of it
send me your but it's out of control
like I do not get work emails I was very
close to being late to our work meeting
today because I could not find that
[__] I couldn't find that email
but one of the things one of the mailing
lists that I will never unsubscribe to
is
um True Swords what's that which is a
it's a website that sells swords
because in my pick me years I realized
the best
sword to or the best present to get a
boyfriend is a sword
you will never you buy a Mana sword
that is I promise you you'll be getting
him his favorite present he's ever been
you're not UK here's where I think
you're absolutely right so
um when Bobby and I moved from apartment
to the new house he basically didn't
care what was left behind except for
some swords some swords yeah and so when
he we keep it by the door and there was
a time where we thought we someone was
breaking into the home and you've
grabbed the sword and present he had he
already had it in his mind how he was
going to defend me and he he went for
the sword and
um it was really and what's he pushing
you in front yeah yeah exactly so he
like threw in front but he had the
katana it was a katana
um right behind me so I do I do this is
my brand of pick me girl being that girl
do you understand that is I have so many
swords so when I used to do mean
inspiration my original solo podcast uh
people kept wanting to send me presents
and I was like really uncomfortable with
that at that point like I just didn't
feel comfortable having people send me
things so I was like all right there's
one stipulation it has to be a weapon
because then I figured if they send me
them it's I can protect myself against
them do you know the energy of but so I
do have a lot of Swords Esther I get the
feeling you're not a sword girl I'm just
really because they're taller than
you're the swords no I like maybe it's
just like the cuck liberal in me but I
am not a weapons girly are you coming
out as a [__] liberal
no I just don't well I'm not a weapons
girl you just said you needed to defend
yourself how are you gonna do that
all weapons weapons like make me so CR
Inge you need weapons you're the one
that needs weapons ding dong
like I'm sure Dave has you know system
in place
but what is he gonna CPAP him to death
if you watch your oxygen is flammable he
could do that and then light them on
fire oh wait a second also your dog is
like the least protective
I want to dive into this because I think
this is a real thing so you're just like
not a weapons girly no I've never had
like a taser you've never had pepper
spray you've never as a girl as small as
you you've never had that
wait I have a trash Tuesday
um this is we're gonna actually I didn't
actually ask you guys this ahead of time
but we're gonna start going on road
trips okay we're doing like we're doing
field trips we're doing field trips I
know what you do on road trips and I'm
scared
Adderall or snort nose oh I'm sorry I'm
gonna be able to read all of those
the signs really well the six Road
actually you on Adderall driving me
around is ideal the amount a lot of time
people think I'm on Adderall where I'm
like I'm on Adderall like once a year
and people like she's not out I'm like
no no no no this is literally this is my
everyday just real pity foreign
this show is sponsored by better help
sometimes you know we're faced with
tough choices in life and the path
forward isn't always clear but I would
always say getting help is the right
thing to do and sometimes it's hard to
get so
better help is a great option to get
started you don't have to worry about
going to an office finding parking
running into people in the building it's
just really simple there's no waiting
you just do it all online and you can
keep a a journal you can switch out with
different therapists it's just a really
easy way
to do what's right for yourself
and you know I always find these these
things that are actually really good for
me I resist them I resist them I resist
them so if there's something like
parking or traffic that's in the way I
will use that excuse as an excuse to not
do it and I think they better help
really cut those excuses out
sometimes in life we are faced with
tough choices and the path forward isn't
always clear that's why meeting with
someone at betterhelp will help you calm
yourself enough to really decide what
the right decision is for you whether
you're dealing with decisions around
career relationships or anything else
therapy helps you stay connected to what
you really want
while navigating your life so you can
move forward
with confidence and excitement
trusting yourself to make decisions that
align with your values is like anything
the more you practice it the easier it
gets let therapy be your map with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com trash
Tuesday to get 10 off your first month
that's
betterhelpglp.com trash Tuesday we're
talking about rocket money it's a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place
because 80 of people that have have
subscriptions usually forget about it
and I am definitely one of those and the
amount of money that I unnecessarily
spend without even knowing is obnoxious
just because I forget to cancel it after
seven days I had one where it was I'm
not even gonna name them because I don't
want to give them free advertisement
even if it is bad like they charged me
for six months I never use the service I
was impossible I was definitely exercise
it was impossible to cancel and Rocket
money will quickly and easily find your
subscriptions for you and for any that
you don't want to pay anymore just hit
cancel and Rocket money will cancel it
for you it's that easy over 3 million
people have used rocket money saving the
average person up to 720 a year rocket
money also helps you manage all of your
finances in one place and automatically
categorizes your expenses so you can
easily track your budget in real time
and also get alerted if anything looks
off stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday that's
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
we have to go shoot guns
try that it's so fun you know what we
used to do in the desert is we used to
fill up like pumpkins scariest sentence
with um water and I didn't think it was
going to be about a pump you guys I
lived in Vegas for years you don't think
that I've shot ARS I have like I'm a
[__] I'm a [__] assault rifle
[__] I dated a guy I lived with a guy
who's like assault rifle guy like he has
so thank you I that's what we did on the
weekends was like shoot guns and shoot
up up into things the many lives a
pretty girl can have just based on the
different guys she's been with it's
really fascinating like yeah it was a
Fox News baby
I mean yeah like this is like I've had I
stayed there a little longer you know
maybe I'd be the opposite of a company
Super Rich
Super Rich right wing Super Rich right
wing I would have been you know you ever
feel the carrot dangle in front of you
of like just being like should I just go
full [__] no because that's fake wait
so we're gonna go out and shoot guns is
what you're saying I like everyone being
on all sides and not knowing where I am
Esther are you down are you gonna have a
weapons day Shadow all over my eyebrows
no you didn't
okay no that would be great I didn't
know you're wearing eyeshadow that's
eyeshadow
that's you with makeup on wait I'm so
sorry did you put makeup on Sir is that
from yesterday no it was never mind
never mind wait I have a I have a I want
to propose something to you Esther so in
the Philippines like the Philippines is
like the birthplace of a lot of weapons
fighting Arnis escrima
um balinta walk like a lot of these
really cool like most of the
choreographers ice cream ice cream
eskrima harness so basically a lot of
like the choreographers for like weapons
fighting even in Hollywood usually have
a background in like Filipino martial
arts because that's where most of like
weapons fighting happened I would love
to have one of those guys teach you how
to do like a you know a bali song like a
butterfly knife she's not gonna do a
butterfly or even the snake fighting
what about Steve she's scared of
butterflies
they are scary if you've ever seen a big
one get close to your head it's it can
be very scary because they're the same
size as though butterflies are like a
monarchs Esther No butterflies are not
scary at any stage in their
metamorphosis also we're scared of just
spiders the butterflies are still bugs
I'm not scared of bugs you ding you know
that Todd has turned into a terrarium
guy we just have like
I'm listening okay you better keep that
man away from me frogs I know you
actually would fit in some of the time
frogs he's a dart frog as poison dart
frog two of them yeah the Gekko yeah
he's a gecko he has a gecko he has a
great he killed one of our crabs and I'm
like really not I started I did my
Academy in my mind Bloom ketamine
treatment and I came out of it and I
started crying about how he killed one
of our crabs wait do you had a crab in
the city yes no Todd has three
terrariums I started uh one week ago and
he has three terrariums now I'm not
gonna end well but Esther do you know
that do you eat like uh shellfish like
lobster or any of that can you get me a
[__] Lobster what is lobster season's
over oh this [__] wait did you just
think she was the waiter no I wanted to
spear it you can't Spirit you just grab
it with your hand you could do it I
would love to do choreographed for the
stage fighting that I'll do any day okay
my school by the way hello oh [__]
yeah I'll fence or do you understand how
funny that actually isn't a true idea
yeah I'm down well for our live stream
like she'd be really good at Jiu Jitsu
because you're a dancer so you're a
naturally very coordinated oh my God and
I would love your little limbs on you oh
my God I think you'd be really good I
think you'd pick it up so yeah take the
earrings out it's annoying I don't
those are just cuffs yeah is that a real
one no this one is not this one is wait
I have a really important question
do you guys want to change your phone
numbers we'll get back to that I do want
to go back to that but this is more
important right now do you like
steak yes
yeah okay I'm having a like something is
wrong with me because we went to a steak
dinner last night for Dave's birthday
and I literally like I was like oh I
like eat more meat now like I'm gonna
actually have to take it does nothing
for me it has like no taste you're like
oh can I just put my stuff in it and
carry them
so annoying uh I don't like steak what
is that it doesn't well how did you get
it cooked yeah well Dave got it medium
rare you oh good good good
I know you're gonna get like well done
you're on autopilot with me
so mad
I actually
think like it better I hate you I hate
your [__] guts you don't deserve to
be here but it's like soft and red you
like that one I like rare like where
it's cold and like yes right like on the
inside so good what is what is can you
tell me why you like it because I'm a
real woman a real person why don't you
just graduate to medium rare start with
medium well don't be so dead do you
understand like if you were born earlier
than this you'd be [__] dead what do
you mean earlier than this like if if
you ever had to hunt or gather or do
anything like I understand why you
Flinch because you're like so little
like you're not you didn't survive
here's how I would survive are you ready
[Laughter]
they would rape you to death
to death no they don't you'd start
talking you're annoying you know you're
annoying it
just mid like there's like a support
group for people that have worked with
this wait hold on well you're annoying
right It's the funniest sentence wait
because I know I'm annoying but I don't
know if you know you don't think I know
I'm annoying are you kidding of course I
know I'm annoying I don't think kalila
knows she's annoying oh my God that's
because I don't get out of the house who
am I annoying to yeah my dogs
no because I am willing to consider an
examine that I am annoying possibly on
this podcast or wherever I'm like in my
real life I was just trying to include
you I didn't want you to get fomo for
annoying no no I want to be annoying but
like to who like my inanimate objects at
home I just do stay home and I play
Legend I just imagine putting them all
inside herself all day what no you when
you go you're sick yeah that was so
gross you guys are Myles are you only
you can tell us that sweetheart it's
true maybe I'm just in an era maybe I'm
just um you don't like big dicks that's
pretty gay that's pretty good that's
pretty gay for me not to like that's
lesbian and [__] really well it's not
not lesbian for sure well the girl that
um I did easy
um kissing with she is really into
straight girls so
I was like oh what a torture and I was
like wait a second I was like am I like
do I read really straight to you and
she's like yeah yeah you're a straight
girl I'm like oh thank you but also like
let's make out that did you ask her what
she thinks of Esther I mean could you
have been more lesbian did you put your
hair back her shoulders out what
um do you do yeah I wonder yeah can she
diagnose me diagnose you well prescribe
well get her tick tock
yeah like give me what my reading you're
just getting read she's getting nervous
she's seeing herself on Tick Tock
getting taken out
teens
um wait can I just though Spotlight my
uh HBO Britney Spears live from Vegas
shirt that I ordered from uh eBay
from like 2000. it's excellent four
thank you it's a great top I'm really
proud of it it's really really good it's
really me I like the hair stubble too on
your armpits oh oh God that was no it's
good that is a lot worse than it's true
it is true it's honest does Dave pluck
your nipple hair no it's not like that
with us oh really yeah
no I'm just like I don't have anybody
for that and you wear like no tweezies
like what do you guys like my favorite
activity to do with
um
a lover is she can't say boy anymore
because we don't love it
it's for them to tweeze my shin hairs oh
it hurts so but it's like an itchy hurt
yeah and it feels so good and it's so
bonding because they wear like a little
headlight
oh my God were they spelunking what is
this I will okay I swear on everything I
am not trying to like you don't have
hair no that's all we've seen I'm not
trying this is not romantic at all I
just think for bonding if we did the
three of us have a sleepover I think
that's like the perfect activity to do
if we all do it together pluck each
other's chin chin hairs Chin Chin Chin
Chin Chin Chin hairs I'll pluck the hair
off your chin no no no no no no no no
I'm gonna pluck your ass here fine come
on okay
yeah I don't really when I get waxed in
my backside I don't feel anything do you
no but that [__] the front pad is the
worst guys I had the worst wax recently
because I hadn't gotten one since I oh
did you go back yeah finally and it was
it was so bad it's not okay I'm like
traumatized I haven't gone back I go
into fight or flight like it's so
painful and horrible well I told you I
did my legs my B of my butt my your bees
yeah I'm trying to get less for you beef
baby you have not heard that one quite
something leave it to beef
um but an armpits and it was just it was
a long it was like two hours I was
losing my mind that's horrible and I was
just butterflied open the whole time
just like okay
here we are
yeah it's just that one main pad though
the sides don't hurt the lips don't hurt
that bad it hurts but like right up
front and center is a pain I just don't
even wear it was so upsetting and I
don't know if I can ever do it again did
you guys watch any of the lularoe
documents oh my God I did I didn't even
know lularoe was a thing so I went in
just with fresh eyes didn't know this
whole like culture existed didn't know
that there was a multi-level marketing
scam that was happening and I with like
fancy leggings because I could have been
a victim of that well they were 25 a
pair I don't think we should call them
fancy leggings but you're right it's
like are you Jewish or not what do you
mean well I wouldn't call them fancy
Also let's be real the Lulu row clothing
makes me so physically uncomfortable
like it's the most ugliest clothing I've
ever seen to the point where I'm like
I'm so uncomfortable with it I think we
need to do a themed episode and all
dressing it well I was oh my God can we
buy it from that that black lady that
was like yeah with a son oh my God she's
not selling it though anymore she has it
all in her oh she does she's in her
garage yeah let's buy it all from her
okay they're just storing it there she
felt so like
um
she like when she felt she was like
blaming herself for not selling it she
was like the only one that hadn't like
Snapped out yet yes we watched this all
three of us watch this documentary on
Max called the rise and fall of lularoe
and it's basically about a multi-level
marketing
um clothing
um brand and where people were basically
scammed into selling clothes basically
similar to what's another weird
Herbalife
they have like Mary okay nail things
yeah like I got you guys know I got like
invited to a meeting for one of these
things once to look for lularoe no for
Arbonne I don't know our bond yeah I I
had to unfollow all of my Arbonne fruit
this is what they're saying is now I
know yeah you sit there he's not cute
look up there compared to what it was
it's
l-u-l-a-r-o-e lularoe why do I feel like
Annie's gonna become a lularoe like rep
I gotta get that Louis Vuitton purse
well when you get me to work under you
what I found the most interesting though
is that somehow you're gonna love me and
take all my money
here's something I know I can guess what
they meant remember they were saying
it's buttery soft yeah I used to like
for um Christmases I would always get
all the women in my family like
ugly leggings that was like a thing and
we would take pictures in our ugly
leggings and they rip immediately like I
know what material these are like the
cheapest but I don't I don't think it's
buttery soft because true buttery soft
is like I I have a Beyond yoga and like
aloe yoga and The Buttery soft ones are
not the shiny ones like this these ones
are soft but and stretchy but they're
not this soft I haven't know how they
tear like I know like I used to get
these weed leggings all the time I'd
have to rebuy them constantly because I
would always tear well the thing that
sucked so bad in the documentary where
you're like oh my God they really just
made this like a game for everyone is
they would encourage the Reps to buy
boxes of the clothes but you didn't know
what and they would say even uglier ones
yeah so you would just get these uglier
and uglier leggings to have to sell and
no one wanted to buy them and then the
worst part is how they talked about like
if you got a box of black leggings those
would sell like that and I'm just like
why can't everyone just get the black
leggings then like why is this why is it
the system is yeah and this is why we
haven't seen any Sleepover by Esther in
a while I guess she doesn't know
anything about my little reps out there
I think it's [__] up that they had to
spend anywhere from like 5 to 10K up
front to even get this mystery box of
clothes that they would have to sell but
what I didn't find surprising is that
Dina and her husband the people who
started lularoe were from a Mormon
church and so that to me that whole
Evangelical kind of really good at
marketing their message types it makes
sense that they were able to convince
people to really get on board because I
think they have the background of church
like that exceptionalism kind of
mentality aren't you Mormon
[Laughter]
I was brought up Horman
uh no I
um had
one of my campers when I worked at
Easter Seals I used to go hang out with
his family all the time is that what I
am to you one of your campers from
Easter Seals I know what that is but
it's special kids with special needs
okay just carry on with your story I
could see you you're about equals like
inabilities as some of my campers thank
you my cerebral palsy
but um I used to hang out go to like
pizza night with them and they um
they had a they would call it their
business and it was like a a place where
they would buy all their groceries and
they would only go to that website and
then they would get other people under
them and then they would each get money
from all the people that were under them
but it was like you had to buy all your
groceries from there and get other
people to buy your groceries from there
I have an idea let's do a a scam no but
like one of our why don't we just like
in our merch site I think we should have
our own special line of Tupperware okay
we can be we can like re you know we can
how do I say Rebrand the whole like
Tupperware party do you understand that
literally in the last two weeks I've
been thinking about hiring an actor to
play out what a classic like 90s 80s
Tupperware party was like like I
literally want to have friends over and
like have a fake Tupperware part like I
want to have that experience that like
all of our moms have I like how it'd be
fake but you like somehow end up with
money
like all of us are broke and you have
all our money maybe in our live show we
should have like a segment that's us
like trying to sell everyone but I
always remember in like the early 2000s
like right out of college I would go to
these like sex toy parties where they
would oh yeah those were fun those
didn't feel like like they'd give you
like [__] lessons yes I thought those
were really cute and fun and they didn't
feel super like culty I do think there
is like a place for like being a woman
or dildos yeah there's a place there's
two places oh my God if you want to
speak it in your mouth speaking of
dildos I have a really huge update for
you guys okay
um you know I have been like anti toys
because then you give yourself a
infection or something no that was the
old blue oh the old the rollover I
remembered
I learned so much from you you cannot
have rollover Lubes I didn't know that
it's a curse you cannot have rollover
Lube one partner per per bottle
so I um I was away for a little bit and
I was really bored and I was going
through some type of like mental
spiraling that day and I was like what
am I gonna do to get myself out of this
funk so I was like I'm just gonna sex
stuff spiraling I'm gonna sex death
Marathon myself I'm gonna [__] myself to
death right and so I was like it sucks
when you can't feel it anymore when
you're like what am I doing this for
well that's what happens it starts to
hurt and then you go into the numbness
everyone out there has always come you
know a random Sunday afternoon like I'm
on a sex death Marathon they are Esther
well like you're not relatable
I'm busy bed rotting okay
I am relatable and so you're just too
lazy to finger yourself
all right what is a sex death Marathon
please so it's when either you're on the
verge of like extreme like a panic
attack which I felt like I was I was
pacing around and I remember one of my
good friends saying like I went through
like years of like extreme like anxiety
but when I would Verge on panic attacks
I would just jerk off furiously and like
common common it would get me out of my
own head because it is such a primal
feeling and so I was having like a
mental health day I was like what do you
do what do I do I'm alone
and so I went to essentially yours and
then I bought a whole lot I channeled my
inner Annie and Esther and I bought like
400 worth of toys wait [__] you what
do you guys have toys right
I have them I have a toys I never yeah
you said you don't leave town like you
panic when you don't have
sure yeah that's true I bring two as a I
have a backup one and I was at the
charger okay okay but the [__] sucker is
all of this stuff like you guys have
that stuff that I've never tried because
I'm like oh I don't want to play with
any of that stuff so I bought 400 worth
of stuff which is really only two things
but I I had I like a mini haul and I was
really excited I was like sex death
Marathon says it was not an unboxing it
was a an inbox
and so I whipped it all out I just you
know I write out the package do you boil
your stuff or do you not yeah right yeah
oil right I'll throw boiling water on
myself to feel again afterwards no I've
never cleaned a vibrator are you insane
oh my God it gets clean listen
it gets cleaned at some point but it's
like it's because there's a point of no
return so it has to happen the vaginas
is self-cleaning cleaning oven and that
applies this is unacceptable actually
we're gross we are bad I disagree don't
I disagree I think you're I think you're
good I think you're so good you're this
is misinformation I think we didn't have
like the covet thing on the bottom
Christmas information you're gonna get
canceled you can go on Dr Drew's podcast
there's no carry-on about your inner
Annie and Esther is that what you call
your each labia yeah yeah Annie one's
bigger one smaller both very annoying
get in the way and um so this is what I
did I had a whole afternoon to myself
and then I went Hog Wild and I this was
yesterday no this is like after us
there's been some time
and I at the end of it all I couldn't
feel my [__] my [__] was completely dead
and that's when you do the stranger when
it feels like you're you're what's a
stranger for girls The Stranger for
girls is where you finger yourself until
you can't feel it and then it feels like
your fingering a stranger oh my gosh
you're fingering someone else oh my god
did you just make that up no
why did you know about that I made it up
but I didn't make it up just now because
I've numbed my [__] many years many a
times but you guys after I was done I
was like I hated that like I don't I
couldn't it just wasn't much
and I put it away I put the boxes away
and I put him on such a high shelf so
that I'll never use them again you will
use them again I will never use them
again that was a one and done my [__] is
dead R.I.P what did you use everything I
even used I had an anal plug I had
everything you did yeah well you put it
went a little crazy will you put an anal
plug I don't have an anal I've never
anal I've never done that I've seriously
like that I gave you one I give you a
cute one remember
but it was real it was like real rabbit
I need to find that oh my God I should
have brought that up in therapy [__]
remember when I've dropped money on you
[__]
money I dropped cash my business manager
is like why'd you buy a 500 butt plugs
look I think do they like it's a gifts I
don't know I don't know I'm trying to
figure out these [__] [__] love
language so I DP'd myself and then after
that I I'm you depleted you DP depleted
yourself I did what no here's the thing
it's double pen and that's it I'm done I
said down there it's I remember someone
once saying to me they went
masturbation's healthy I go not the way
I do it I go like four hours past it
feeling good oh is still here no okay
that's what I was doing because I would
come and I was like oh got one more in
there I know I have one more in there
and I was this I don't usually watch
porn in this way but I had it on for
hours your pillow princess and yourself
you're like oh and if I had even one
negative self thought I was like back in
there
press play it was insane it was an
insane thing but it did get me out of my
head that day it just kept me in Primal
mode that is true it's I could see that
being meditative and it was hitting this
okay yeah well what's your review of
having a butt plug-in by yourself
um it was okay so I'm not a big anal
girl like I'm afraid of anal so I was
like why don't I just control the
narrative here because when dudes
usually do it I'm like you know like I
don't oh my God and it is it's better to
be a part of why they like it too it's
like guys do you like that it's like
there's you know it's kind of hurting us
I think so I think that's part of it I
don't know uh what is yeah I think it's
just that it's like forbidden yeah and
like no no really naughty yeah I think
that's what it is I don't know but if it
does feel slightly better when you do it
yourself I think Hmm
I'm like you don't have to go in my
[__] you can be around it I love
around a round is like that's oh my God
Esther's an anal princess I didn't say
that why are you why are you saying that
I just feel like if a dick went in your
ass it would like poke your head
like what is it happening up here why is
this it's a full it's a little Kebab
just pull it out an Esther kebab
[Laughter]
you two are really honestly sickening me
remember when I told you one of your
ex-boyfriends was like she's a freak
shut up who said that well there's one
of two I can be telling you okay and
it's I would say the nicer one uh but
the maybe more embarrassing one stop
just stop right there you're done but I
but you reacted better to it this time
you're like he did stop
last time you're like ew why did he say
that and I was like I think it was
before
probably well anytime like yeah I'm I'm
at peace now with my past now I know
you're a flexi I am not though that's
not even true
I don't I don't even think it's yours I
think that same person was the one going
around telling like other male Comics
that like your [__] was delicious I
think that was someone else oh
thank you so much do you guys think I
should get
um trap talks what's up
it's Botox on my traps because you know
I'm over developed here and I might you
know I'm kind of like you're something
is gonna pick it up somewhere else and
be [__] weird as [__] you know that
right no wait what some other muscle is
gonna pick that up pop it out in some
weird spots you're not gonna have to
stop asserting the same amount of energy
it's just gonna go to a different area
right because I think I've over
developed traps because I hold tension
here and I do this a lot but also I was
starting to relax just work on relaxing
sounds again with trap talks what's your
butt plug-in [__]
what I see people talking about is like
that they think it makes them look
better which I think is actually so
disturbing like literally what you're
like I was born without traps and I look
like [__] no but like well won't we do
to our bodies like to just they
literally get BOTOX in here so that who
gives a [__] about this it's not for a
pain no no it's not it's literally so
that you have like and your neck looks
longer I think I actually yeah I got it
now I want you to get it I want you to
get all of them for pain I would I'm
like support that but for looks is weird
I've always had overgrown traps
no it's not a thing it is wait you're
doing a position though to make it look
that way you guys there's a reason why
I'm like I I'm an amazing stand up
straight I'm amazing at deadlift
actually the one over the deadlift is
here but I was a I swam butterfly so
I've always had overgrown traps I've had
over cool that's great that's a badge of
honor do you want trap talks I don't
know you
you're the one who sent it to me because
I just think oh that's so rude
can we have her um can we send it to you
too
I'm glad see sometimes
but can we do a fat transfer of your
shitty [__] shoulders on her
non-existent shoulders I sent it to you
I like my body you guys I just want to
like myself no this is so this is
actually really interesting
about yourself I didn't send it to you
to because I thought you should get it I
sent it to you guys because I thought it
was absurd that women are like going
around being like look at how beautiful
I am now that I might try and sorry I've
been seeing a lot of women um before
their weddings because they have to wear
um like tube dresses or show expose
their shoulder and neck they're getting
have to
you know they don't have to but girls
are like I'm absolutely gonna let me see
it before Botox in my traps
but what's it for what was initially
like why did someone try this
this is like your traps are holding up
your head this is like what are we doing
I have a big head to hold on I'll just
look cute oh
he's cute
no I brought it up oh my God I want to
put a butt plug in and look at before
and after
we should do an episode where we all
wear butt plugs
and just our asses on you don't want to
use it if you don't want to save it for
the sleepover or that if you prefer your
idea yeah I'll take your idea I saw this
old picture of Kendra Wilkinson of girls
next door Fame the best show of all time
um she was wearing this tank top was
very like Y2K and it said I have the
[__] so I make the rules and I know
that is like meant as a joke but when
you think about it as like from an
existential place
we are because we have the womb
literally men's survival what I just
it's like you learn things that are like
very obvious yeah but very late in life
and it's so weird no no no no you we are
the choosers this whole time I thought
like a man has to a man a man has to
choose me but no it's like we are their
survival depends on our wombs so we
actually are in charge this I know
that's meant as a joke I have the [__]
side of the car but it's actually true
and he clip it he never felt like the
Chooser in your life
oh no Chosen One
no I have never felt in like a Chooser
I've always felt like uh like the the
Chooser have you
maybe not when I was super young but
like you know maybe 25 and over
definitely yeah I mean as you evolve as
a person yeah and I was never like
choose me choose me I've never been in
that you're like a tadpole of a person
this is crazy
you've always known this is you like are
you pandering to a younger audience
right now why because I look small this
is a child like no no I I know it's the
same thing no it's just you just grow
out of it you just grow out of that you
didn't but that's a good message for so
you're ultimatum [__] you're totally
the Chooser yeah like once we got
together but I just I truly always you
wanted him to like you you know what
also this is like [__] Sex in the
City brainwashing rhetoric like oh we're
gonna be single we need a man like no
we're supposed to that's that is the
opposite of what we're saying I just
flashed forward to like 20 years from
now and I'm like I won't do a cameo on
this and then you guys pay me enough
when I do a phone camp
Oh for um Samantha
is that all she did was a phone Cameo
wait are you serious
but all the headlines
don't you want to know that well we have
a pipeline towards it oh yeah but he
doesn't know where he's at yeah he
doesn't know anything he doesn't know
what day it is he hardly remembers his
name you think he's gonna know he knows
Kim Cattrall Sarah SJP drama I love when
she's like I like when she goes I just
feel like that character is done and
everyone's like we want it and she's
like sorry I mean that is [__] bold
and then she's like all right I'll come
back how much money do you think that
[__] voice Cameo is she's goals
that's like crazy she's like okay I
don't know she calls in
it's like a 10 million dollar phone call
potentially so smart
and everyone's just like you know
slaving away day to day on set and she's
just like Sarah Jessica Parker's wearing
like birds on her head still for the
25th year in a row
but do you do you really
do you you're trying to tell me that you
already know and have that in your body
that like it took me a while to get
there it took me about it but you I
always knew that was like the goal and I
knew that like I you do know like the
power that you have you're like I make
the babies you know what no you know
what it is I think it's when you when
you get old enough to realize I think
for me when I was younger I if every one
didn't like me
I didn't think anyone liked you know
what I mean so I needed every guy to
like me or every and that just wasn't so
I would take like the rejection of like
oh if they don't want me I'm not like of
value but it's like I do like understand
that the woman's body is
but I mean we also need guy's farm so
it's not it's just we have to do all the
stuff so but I do think that's an
important thing to or remember
especially if you're in a position where
you feel like oh like I hope he chooses
me to be like no no no no like you you
have the control you're in the freaking
Driver's Seat but anxious attachment is
like for me I would be dating guys and
I'd be like oh I hope they like like I'd
want these answers from them and I
didn't even get to a place where I could
decide whether I wanted to be with them
yet because I was so overwhelmed with
like that they figuring out whether they
like yeah yeah but I also think
specifically with that shirt it's like I
would probably have looked at that like
10 years ago or whatever and been like
oh yeah like you have the post you have
the power like men want to have sex so
you're in control but it's so much
deeper than that it's literally like no
you can't your genes can't be passed on
without this [__] yeah
your seed can girl without me yeah
you're just a seed you're just spunk
like you're just white creamy things
there's like so many sperms too like
yeah so there's like many two million or
so how many sperm are in a load
and only like one or two gets through
it's like really actually quite pathetic
it's pathetic
but you know there's a hundred million
sperm in each load wow 100 million isn't
that crazy yeah cream pie just one cream
pie a hundred million sperms a million
babies can you believe you survived out
of that many that how is medic were
those others that's amazing
and the fact that they were maybe a
little slower since their daddies were
old yeah and you're a twin what does
that even mean I have no clue I still
don't understand same egg no two eggs
fertilized at the same time
by different sperms yes I don't know I'm
you think I'm a co-spirm we would have
identical twins you know what after I
feel after yeah we're split before yeah
oh I feel like your brother got in there
first and you're like I kicked him out
when he was born when we were born he
came out first and then I came out feet
first
like I kicked him physically out and no
one can tell me like my mom would be
like we were just kidding and I'm like
remember that joke and she was like oh
they weren't kidding does does your mom
ever talk about like that it was really
hard to carry two at once she I have
never in my life felt like my mom
chose to have me anyway she was always
like she was like I was so overwhelmed I
only wanted two children oh I'm like
okay [__] playing baseball stuff I
wonder which kid you wanted the boy or
the girl the short hair on her baseball
hat oh I wonder which one you were but
that is crazy can you imagine like you
already have one and then you want one
more and you get two well my my when
they were in doing the ultrasound and
they found out it was twins my dad was
like yes and my mom just started like
crying but my mom like my mom had um her
mom died right when she was pregnant
with me so right before she found out we
were twins so that was probably like the
most devastating thing and her mom had
been her mom was diagnosed with ovarian
cancer when my mom was 15 and she went
to like boarding school and they brought
her into the office and were like your
mom has like six months to live but she
doesn't want you to come home oh my God
she didn't want to like disrupt her
education or whatever so then my mom had
was like like couldn't be with her mom
and then her mom ended up living for
another 15 years after that so my mom
was 31. and then she ended up dying
right with my mom she got to meet Timmy
which was good but then she died right
when my mom was
right before she found out she was
pregnant with twins so like I think
that's like
everything she was adopted like there's
like a lot with my mom you know I think
um that reminds me of something that I
often Overlook about my mom when we when
we came to America we didn't have a lot
of money at all like a lot like paycheck
to paycheck my dad's like veterans pay
like very like our rent was like 350 a
month in like this one bedroom place and
my mom
my grandma my my mom's mom so my mom's
brother died uh maybe two years into us
being in America we still didn't really
have a lot of money and he was in the
Philippines yeah and so one of her
brothers killed the other brother and
then a month later my grandma died and
imagine my mom who's so close to her so
wait your uncle's the the are the
murders are your mom's Brothers your
mom's brother killed your her other
brother wait and then that's my grandma
then died from the Heartbreak of I'm
taking it in honestly hold on but she
could not go home you guys she does say
these things very normal she does
um but she could not go home she was
still on like I don't think her Green
Card had been like fine how many other
siblings were there
um she they're a total of ten but it was
her mom like she recently told me she's
like
I I couldn't go home to my mother I
couldn't be by her side and it's not
like like it's because she couldn't like
just her visa wouldn't allow it her the
money couldn't allow it and it was just
heartbreaking I was like my mom endured
this trauma in her 40s of not being able
to go back to her mother and I really
feel for her like imagine that imagine
if something happened to her parents and
we couldn't get to them we couldn't grow
whoa that happened to so many people
during covet and stuff my mom was just
telling me that she met this woman at a
memorial that one of my for one of my
dad's friends and um
and she was saying like her husband got
sick during covet and she had to put him
into her she couldn't take care of him
so she'd put him into a nursing home and
it was like I think right before she put
him in the nursing home and then coveted
it and she couldn't so she didn't get to
be with him and she's like still
recovering from it just the trauma of
not being with him
yeah it's like it's so sad it's like
it's so I think it's like why it's so
important if you can like
do all of your work with people like as
soon as possible in your forgiveness and
your talks with a mother alive because
you will be able to get there but it's
like so much easier when they're like
still with you'd have to process all
that stuff after someone dies is like
but the fact that a nursing home has the
right to not allow you to it wasn't all
right it was covered it was like no one
was allowed to go anywhere remember no
one could go in and see anyone
I know it's so sad but I I know what
you're saying and then my mom like my
mom's been really
um she's been doing a lot of meditation
and stuff and she's she's just like was
saying to me she's like I I think about
you every time I do it because I think
about my mom and she's like there's just
this like woman connection that I have
with you guys and she's like I just am
and she's like always so sweet like
she's really we're like in a really good
wow Vibes place and sweet but I always
think about it too like with all the
stuff like because I told my [__]
high schools around Ryan Sickler's
podcast again and God it's just like I
just get [__] torn open every time I
[__] tell it as much as I think I'm
okay it's like it really gets me and
then it's like you know people always
want to like
I mean
that's definitely not the episode read
comments on it's like one of those but
it's like you know the people that like
get mad at my parents for like not
protect me or whatever like I just I
always try to say like it's like when
when I die and when my parents died like
the only thing that I would take with me
is like the way I love them you know
it's not I'm not gonna hold on to like
any yeah 100 other [__] like imagine if
you were to look at life based on like
just one season of your life one season
of your parents life you've lived a ton
of lives like think about where you were
when you're 19 where you are now like
even in between that like I feel like
how many lives have I lived yeah the
fact that also you're even saying that
with like the words YouTube comments
even in the conversation it's like of
course that doesn't matter of course it
doesn't matter at all yeah but I mean I
guess for me it's like because that was
something that I like struggled when I
when I tell the story it's like I'm I'm
conscious of the fact that I'm now
giving this to like be interpreted by
like strangers I think that's a good
right I think that's a good thing to
talk about it's like you know we talk
about our parents in a very like factual
way but this is what happened this is
how they hurt me whatever whatever but
like we're all really close to our
parents today yeah like a reminder to
everybody that like like you know
parent-child relationships like a very
nuanced like ongoing Journey but like
just because my mom was that person back
then to me it doesn't mean she's this
person today also we don't even remember
yeah I was gonna say we're all
unreliable narrators but they also that
they say 50 of like your memory is like
exaggerated or whatever it's true and
you're able to convince yourself off
like if you were coping in that moment
at 16 like that whatever you believe can
then be your new truth like you you can
form like synapses with the wrong memory
like that that can happen but also the
like the moment you're talking about
which is like it is funny like you're
that they found out it was twins your
dad was excited your mom was crying like
that if you take like
take that microcosm it's like so of all
men and women like because the women
have to do so much yeah so my dad was
looking at like ego style like my
[__] sperm made Twins and my mom's
like are you [__] kidding me
[__] like I totally empathize
with your mom there because she's like
knows what that and then they're growing
in you and you don't know what that does
to your body her mom had literally just
died too it's like it's just so and it
had been that like long like to be told
your mom has six months to live and then
she lives 15 years and then like so it's
like all the anxiety she must have had
that whole time also I imagine that if I
if I were to ever get pregnant that my
mom would be my number one Ally like she
would be the person who would be my
[__] coach from beginning to end I
need that I can be my worst self with
her I don't have to worry about how my
hormones are gonna either end this
relationship she's there no matter what
it's just I can be my most
ugly hormonal self and she can just kind
of walk me through the season in my my
life like that's how I see my mom right
how old is your mom she's in her 60s
she's 60. too but by the way I want to
say
um that when you mentioned your whole
like teacher story thing the reason that
the girl that I made out with over the
weekend and I actually made out is
because she told a story about
um like we had just like we were talking
about like sexual traumas and she had a
very similar story as like yours and
immediately I felt like super like
bonded to her she had just watched the
room thank you
to my high school teacher again let's
post together so yeah and so her thing
was like this teach she hadn't had her
glow up yet she's really pretty now but
like she was this kid who like no one
kind of paid attention to except for the
teacher and she was like oh he sees like
my potential so he would like give her
gifts things like that then she told me
the story and I felt like I was like oh
I think
and then you know we love you God
because that's because you really want
to kiss me
I did not love that story it is awesome
it is like it is weird like okay because
I'm like I thought like I could
intellectualize that I could be like you
know I'm doing ketamine treatment like
I'm you know I can separate myself from
it the other night I just went crazy I
was in Baltimore I was in my hotel room
alone I went deep diving finding these
people I was like I mean there's just
things that feel unresolved I think and
I don't know if I have to resolve them
myself or very publicly I don't know
what it is but well we've talked about
this amongst each other it's like do we
out these people because I asked you
guys you know I sent you like the court
case of the doctor and he's obviously
like the Doctor Who
Um sexually assaulted my sister and I
he's lost his license he's like not oh
you know you saw the court cases that I
sent you he's in big big trouble right
but I think for you like I feel for you
because it it does feel more unresolved
when I look for my perpetrator it's
clear
he's still out there he's like fine it's
like and I did the thing I sat in corn
exactly so it's so frustrating I didn't
sit in court but I have more of a
resolve like a resolution in mind
because I see that he's being he's
paying the price for what he did to me
yeah and I think for you Annie like what
really breaks my heart and I think why
he did block me on Instagram oh well
that's a win and I saw like there was
some like he's not like that like he
can't be there's oh you must be his
worst nightmare oh I can't wait I like
and then he and then so and then he like
there was something like one little clip
of him on YouTube and the only comment
was predator
can you imagine if you molested someone
in it wrong girl wait can I just tell
you that's how I felt the whole time I
was like are you crazy like obviously
I'm gonna go to the police like I'm
gonna go to the bodega guys
a podcaster and comedian like I was like
duh and then and like okay so then I
looked up this is where I got triggered
I looked up his ex-wife who was like 100
involved in the grooming of all of it
was she in court with him
um I don't think she went to court no
she didn't get any no nothing happened
to her but she lives very close to us
she lives an hour drive from us and I
looked I found her on Instagram and I
saw all of her
she follows a bunch of female comedians
that I'm friends with and I'm like oh do
you like female comedians you [__]
and she makes mugs I want to be like
cute mugs where's your mug shot [__]
like do you know how close I was to
commenting that on one of her her things
whoa you like female comedian like it
just triggered me so much and by the way
like
this is like my anger inside of me
that's still there so it's like I don't
know I just I'm like there's just
something like and I don't know if it's
this is this thing I can just like fold
up and like bury or if it's like I just
don't know what if it's for me to like
release more information publicly or if
it's for me to like release my ties to
this or maybe question because I'm like
yeah what is it at least for me it's the
acceptance that I allow it to affect me
however which way it affects me that day
yeah some days I feel stronger some
months I feel stronger and then some
days I want to [__] rage out and burn
someone's house and I think that I I'm
nice to myself in those days and I'm
like okay this is normal it's you know
my my rage Bubbles and then it's back
down my rage Bubbles and I think the
acceptance of knowing that this is
probably gonna be something I carry with
for the rest of my life in different
ways
makes me like sleep a little better yeah
and it's just like
you know but I know I mean I know what
you're saying and it's like it's just
for me like I had just like one like
very crazy train you're right it's like
forgive yourself for that but it's like
I was like texting Josh Potter like
picture screen he's like stop sending
these pictures like no I don't want to
see that I'm like sending him pictures
I'm like look at this [__] ass look
at and he's like oh my God he's like and
he's like Annie you just have to like
focus on how good your life is like you
know like really which is good advice
because I'm like I was like spinning and
um and then in the morning I was like oh
my God delete those pictures I'm sorry
oh my God but I was like we're taking
them down like we're gonna go find you
know because like part of me just it's
like I get it the rage fantasies I get
but it's like it's just like it is there
and I do have this platform and it's
like there are I could Scorch the Earth
yeah and I'm like why am I not is it out
of like protection myself or am I still
protecting this but even imagine if you
go scorched Earth and you still don't
feel better you know what I mean like
it's just there's this part of me that's
like the school is not being held
accountable they've had so many other
predators that I've found out about that
were not this was not just this person
this was like an establishment as well
so there's like this larger thing and
the fact that some of those teachers are
still there not the ones that I that did
anything but the ones that were like
complacent and involved and were the T
it's just like how is that school still
going how is there no like newspaper
article about it I would do it what did
my parents sign like what the [__] did
they sign some sort of like silence
thing or whatever
I don't realize that there's no like I
can't find it I'm the public record of
it
yeah that can I I see how that's like
super and I'm sure I can find court
documents like I'm sure like my dad was
like at one point like I'll help you but
they it's like it's also so upsetting
for my parents like they can uh so
they're like they just shut down when I
bring it up they're like stop talking
about it like don't worry about it like
stop Annie like yeah and my dad will
like defend the school like the school
is good for some kids it's like but I
don't care like if the school is good
but like that will show itself
and the more I investigate and stuff but
they want me to be good and they also I
think
it's just too much for them exactly no
that to me that makes so much sense it's
like they love you so much that it's
probably so challenging to their reality
to even go there the reality that's what
it is but it's like I don't want like
right now my parents are 72 and my dad's
turning 82 like I they have like
anxieties my dad like last time I was
home he's like
he's worrying about like he doesn't want
to be a burden to us and it's like I
want to like help him understand that
it's like my pleasure to like take him
however he is yeah and it's like and
then like a lot with the money I'm
having such like anxiety about money and
how I like I've spent and I don't have a
house and stuff because I would love for
my dad to like to take care of my
parents like I love that and Todd's like
Todd's family always had all of his
grandparents and stuff so now I'm like
I'm starting to like regret the way I
had been with my money in the past you
know but I still want that Louis Vuitton
one little one that's one little one
what you're saying now are like such
normal relatable anxieties it's like
literally I don't know a person in this
country that's not like stressed about
how they spent their money and wishing
like all right like what you're saying
is literally the most normal but it's so
important also to not like I enjoyed
spending every [__] penny I spent
last year like yeah and it felt really
good and it was like so exciting for me
and I do still feel like I live in
abundance and stuff but it's like right
now the fact that I can't like Snap My
Fingers and have like a [__] compound
where like Todd's parents and my parents
can all just like live with us and like
hang out but like everyone everyone
wants to stab their fingers but I think
what's so special about what you're
saying like even though like you're
expressing it as something that is like
a stressor in your life like a financial
thing like I see it as like wow you've
come to the part of your life where like
like not only are you able to do these
nice things for your parents and provide
but now there is like you're getting
closer to the dream of like having your
parents live closer to you and maybe
like you know see them at like you know
this time in their life like I don't
know I think like
you know it's a privilege for me now to
feel the stress the financial stress
because I've taken on the responsibility
of my mother of a lot of people in my
family and even though it's a difficult
responsibility like I do it with
pleasure like you said like yeah
it makes me happy I never do it like oh
[__] I have to do this I'm like no I get
to do this this was my dream I wanted to
make enough money to do this for them so
that they never have to worry so they my
mom never has to take out her credit
card like I feel good I know but I also
like look into it I'm like there is an
unhealthy aspect of it big time where
it's like it's guilt like where I'm like
I'm almost like apologizing for my
existence like I want to like and and
that's the thing that like worries me
like that well because I've been having
a lot of like what are they called
nocturnal panic attacks where I keep
like waking up in the middle of the
night put it here girl [__] yeah and I
do I I can't tell you how much work I do
on myself like I mean I literally like I
do treatments therapy bees everything
like I mean I'm really working on it and
I do have like I am losing I have like
an an addiction and a habit to anxiety
and I just have to like really work on
on right now Esther you don't get
nocturnal panic attacks no oh my little
[__] with them it's like a period it's
still not fun your oxygen depleted
you're not breathing it's [__] scary
or disoriented you don't know where the
[__] you are I don't have but I don't
have night terrors which is like crazy
my boyfriend had night terrors where he
would like he would lunge like I would
wake up and you'd be like my face like
I'm dead I'm dead I'm like you're not
dead but am I about to be dead
scared for my life
my life all where he was or anything I
just wake up like with full like like
we're and it'll be very mundane things
that are not like that but it is all I
think surrounding really like taking on
a lot of my parents anxiety and like but
so in these situations it's like if
they're going like I don't want like we
like when you talk about this it's like
upsetting to us it's like hard for me to
imagine doing like a documentary about
it you know what I mean yeah but but
it's their separate thing yeah exactly
yeah but honestly everything you're
saying right now is like so spot-on
relatable like in to everyone in
different ways like
yeah I just think like I relate to
everything you're saying I'm like oh
that's so something I'm working on too
is like my anxiety like yes yours pops
you up at night but like my intrusive
thoughts throughout the day like I'm
constantly working on managing that it
is so hard like yeah I just feel so
connected to everything you said and
also like I used to always be like I
need to move my parents out here and
then I remember I did Maria menounos's
podcast and her mom and dad had like
moved out from Boston to live with her
and her husband and they were like well
like it may not like they were very much
like you need to like put the brakes on
any kind of like that may not be the
right thing and that yeah shifted my
perspective and like I love my parents I
[__] love them I love taking them out
to dinner like I love visiting them but
I don't necessarily want them like next
door anymore I love you guys yeah and
it's also like I don't know how it's
gonna end up like I don't know but it's
like I do like I feel like the the idea
that's not an option for me right now is
that's where it's like oh you know but
they don't even want that either it's
like they don't want to [__] live
with me but they're like what are you
talking about it's just you know I just
want them to like I just want them to
have like the least burden on them right
now what did our parents do to us that
we like are so desperate for them it's
really interesting we're so pathetic
about them so obsessed with them I don't
know what happened yeah thank you for
sharing that Annie I think that's going
to resonate with a lot of people only
because it's like we are at that age
where we do have to consider that our
parents are aging and we at some point
we will be their caretakers and that is
a reality for so many people and um we
unfortunately in America we live in a
very like nuclear family system where we
don't live with
um you know extended family members who
can assist in the caretaking or have
those different jobs like that's why I
always tell my mom when you're ready to
move back to the Philippines I'm still
gonna do this podcast
um but you know everything there is a
community effort we go with her yeah I
would buy her a home there you guys
gonna do episodes there too
but you know it's kind of like that
thing where it's like there's always
someone there to help it's not just a
two three four person household there's
usually about 15 like taught okay so
yeah like they obvi they have so Todd's
Three Brothers or two brothers they had
both sides of the grandparents live with
them and like I mean Todd saw them die
like I mean it's like the whole thing
yeah they never went and nursing comes
around I love that I think that also is
part of like capitalism right and the
reason why I think a lot of you know
Americans in general like are generally
sadder and you go to other countries
that are live in abject poverty but you
see their families and you're like okay
[__] up things happen but there is a
feeling of support in motherhood and
aging in a lot of different ways that I
pose an argument against you both which
is like
because I really did used to be all
about this like I want to live with my
parents forever like I grew up in my
this the house that my grandparents
bought like but
like doesn't it feel really great to
like go home and it's just you and Todd
and it's like no no I'm not saying that
this is like the but it is it is like
and same to you are you you really want
to live with your mom like not my mom
but like having people in the house
hearing the buzz of like family and
support yeah someone always gonna play
with my hair like I love it but what if
you just met like some great guy and you
want to like he might die and then it's
gone that support is gone that's what
she thought that's what she thought that
was her first thought wait what if I
Rely if I put on my head he might die I
didn't even look I didn't even look she
just immediately went to he might die
and then I'll be gone wait okay so
you're planning something this is why
she has 47 dogs
I just learned that the reason that I
have 47 dogs by the way is from complex
PTSD that is a Hallmark sign like
throwing all of your like effort into
things that yeah like dog people usually
have some type of like complex drama
yeah concerned I'm like oh it makes
sense I even when my plate is so full
I'm gonna get two more Foster dogs
usually blind and usually like dragging
their legs and I need to because it's
soothing myself even though it's like I
would love to be like oh she's so you
know she's so great she really wants to
help dogs I do but I also want to help
myself against me to check on Whitney
and Miranda Cosgrove here at this news
um I yeah my dad I was always like I'm
gonna buy you a house Dad and he like he
would be like I think at this point it
might just be a really nice urn
but I know you're saying too it's like I
don't have to it's not like
it's not like I have to but it is
something I would like to have as an
option I think the compound idea is
really nice like when you want to be so
awesome so awesome to just imagine
Esther and be rich enough to have people
like you know helping out I just think
honestly what's coming up is like if
your dad
like thought that you in any way felt
like you yeah he wouldn't want that
you'd be like [__] you he doesn't want
to be a burden I mean that's like the
whole your dad loves you you're all that
matters he was just like he's like my
two great aunts like they needed to be
strapped down I'm like you're not gonna
need to be a strap down but I'll strap
your ass down
my dad took a diaper full of his own
[__] and like slap my sister with it he
had a a moment of no Lucidity like he
were you a little jealous what about me
he was like who the [__] are you and
then he then called me on the phone
because I wasn't there and he was like
there's a stranger in my home she's
trying to rob me and I could hear my
sister in the background be like Papa
it's me oh and he was like [__] up her
face trying not to get pink eye
sling his [__] at her I love that Kyle
already went through all the trauma of
all her care when she was like 14. I did
I really did that's okay again it was my
pleasure yeah like it was all of our
pleasure it was very painful but it was
good to be by his side to the very end
yeah well you guys have the very end
this is going to be our last episode
just kidding we will thank you for being
here we love you we shared we laughed we
cried we got a little wet in the butt um
we'll see you guys next week plug it up
Brandon don't forget to plug it up
let us know what you think about plex in
the comments bye guys
[Music]
thank you